- [Presenter] Revolving doors
always open, always closed.
So, why do we have them?
(bouncy music)
Meet Theophilus Van Kannel.
A curmudgeon and a scrooge of sorts.
- Humbug!
- [Presenter] He hated lots of things.
None more so than chivalry,
especially opening doors
for women.
He also hated and I mean
hated that awkward dance
we've all experienced.
- After you.
- No, after you.
- [Man] No, no, no, I insist after you.
- [Second Man] After you.
- [Presenter] Van Kannel
created a way to eliminate
his social phobia by drawing inspiration
from a preexisting German,
(speaking in foreign language).
Translation: door without draft of air.
In 1888, Van Kannel
received a patent for a
storm door structure
aka the revolving door.
In 1899, the first one
was installed at Rector's,
a restaurant in New York City.
It was revolutionary!
Not only did it eliminate
forced social interaction,
revolving doors kept
dust, rain, sleet, snow,
and noise from entering
buildings and kept the heat
and air conditioning inside.
Seems great, energy efficient,
but there's a catch.
No one uses them.
In 2006, an MIT study found
only 20% to 30% of people
were using the revolving doors.
So, why don't we use them?
Probably because swinging
doors are just easier,
but Mr. Van Kannel, we salute you
and your anti-social ways.
(tambourine music)